[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at long now and it's
great to see all of you here a couple
announcements one is that we'll be doing
the member picture how many members in
the audience tonight nice so all of you
members immediately afterwards come up
here and don't fall into the organ and
we're gonna take a picture right after
the show the other announcement is that
there's another screening of this
tomorrow night at the Internet Archive
and as of an hour ago there was still a
few more seats so for your friends who
didn't make it tonight make sure they do
make it to that it's a fundraiser for
the internet archive's fire so you
should donate to that even if you aren't
able to make it but it's a worthy night
to go again or send your friends to and
stewart's can introduce Rick I'm Stuart
brand long now
[Music]
long now is in part about taking the
future personally in the past personally
and I learned a little about this doing
shows about extinct species and for
example the thylacine the tasmanian
tiger is this marsupial wolf that was in
Australia and Tasmania and in this
slideshow I show a beautiful color
painting of the animal and it's kind of
beautiful and then I show a
black-and-white photograph of a dead
Tyler scene and the hunter that killed
him
that's kind of tragic and then I show
some last one died in 1936 I show some
film was shot in the zoo of the last
thylacine and this is basically a happy
dog just bouncing around and going up
the wall and and just being so alive
film video is completely different from
still photographs and paintings and
that's why I think Rick Prelinger is the
person who brings the past more to life
than anybody here's Rick doing it
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart
so there's a Red Cross here for me to
stand on I'm gonna stand here um thank
you number eight you know every year it
gets a little bit easier to emcee this
and a lot harder to edit so um hope it
works how many of you have been to a
show before that's how many of you have
been to almost every show okay okay
respect your elders so welcome to the
eighth I can't believe it's the eighth
uhm this show more than ever is made up
of home movies very special records
records of personal expression rather
than corporate or institutional or
government expression made possible made
possible as part of this program by the
fabulous film scanner at Internet
Archive which is unfortunately no more
because of our disastrous fire on
November 6 so please support long now
and support Internet Archive if you can
um
what's to say about this this event
isn't as much isn't nearly as much about
the past in my mind as it is about the
future it's of course about these
wonderful images of a city that is no
longer in activities that are to some
extent extinct in the body language and
the look and the cultural geography of
our city but it's also very much about
the city that we would like to live in
and let's keep that in our mind and
let's also remember that this is not
about one San Francisco this is about
many San Francisco's that exist within
you know the particular coordinates of
the tip of this peninsula I need your
help to make the show better to make it
more diverse to make it more interesting
so please dig into your family home
movie archives let me know what you got
we can figure out how to get it in here
most importantly as I think most of you
know by now this is a participatory
event you are the soundtrack we are the
soundtrack you are the soundtrack
that's better um I'd like you know I'll
yell yourselves hoarse no actually I'd
like you to UM identify as much as you
can to engage with one another if you
dispute anybody's particular
identification um shout out ideas
there's really no there are no
restrictions on free speech in here
there's also no photographic
restrictions except no flash um so have
fun this is 72 minutes afterwards I'll
be around to talk to people outside
thank you so much for coming and
remember you're the soundtrack
[Applause]
day
you guys are so good
though as early 40s or late 30s
yes cow pressure is
very old footage courtesy of the Market
Street Railway in Ric logic shouldn't ya
and we're just getting the you know the
safety material out of the way first
showing how dangerous it used to be to
try to catch a car on Market Street
some of these shots are firmly a film
made in 1937 encouraging people to vote
for the construction of the Market
Street subway that's how long it takes
to build things in San Francisco
no hint of a nanny state
streetcar historians and the Pentagon
look
this is about 1934 this as an outtake
from an independent feature film a
process plate meant for real projection
out the back of a fake taxicab probably
so during a conversation this is what
you would see okay angle side
[Music]
[Applause]
you know Hearst building at market and
third
here's a little bit of a labor parade
[Music]
[Applause]
shot by a Hollywood crew has just stock
footage late 40s this is around when was
that Transit strike 1949 ish people are
parking in the middle of Market Street
Yeah right
Valencia it straight on Sunday more
warfield theater oh okay this is about
1978 remember this New Year's Eve it's
not allowed anymore but office workers
would save their desk calendars and
throw them out the window this was
before windows were made not to be
opened
[Applause]
I'll take
outtakes for me what it's going it takes
from the official San Francisco Visitors
Bureau film I went back and read about
this and apparently kids would hang out
in the in the trash and try to put
together a complete year of desk
calendars
I may be wrong but I think when when
Robert Redford's film the candidate was
being shot they used this as a ticker
tape parade to save money here's the
short-lived seaplane ferry between
Oakland and San Francisco six minutes I
think I can
I know we've just seen this in the last
couple years but
thank you
new system Oakland no East Shore Empire
so for those of you who don't know the
ferry would would go to that terminal
where you catch your train into the East
Bay and in a minute we're gonna actually
see where that is from the air is
everybody going to see the Bay Bridge
troll at the Oakland Museum highly
recommended that was that's the key
system via our camera tipped its focus
to record for posterity the passing of
the first trans pacific ocean liner
under the completed bridge and she
belches forth for deep throated roar in
respect at the same time our airplane
motors wells the singing saga of
modernity to this jewel of steel as
complicated as a labyrinth yet just
simple as the highways of rome are these
intercommunicating rents that spread out
their fingers to greet the motor
voyagers of those who seek the mainland
the geometrical ease with which traffic
uses to a minimum the duties 40 highway
patrolman who police the area and
tomorrow's motor vehicles and spin along
and the broad ramps free from the
dangers of bad intersection
anticipating the commercial attribute
the engineers have fully prepared for
the heavy mechanized industries who will
send their trucks carrying the products
of California to the four corners of the
globe Navy national march jauntily for
women around by listening with the joy
of achievement they paraded in
[Music]
and right in there a deal with these
floating touch of the early West was
reconstructed in our memories by this 20
Mule Team that added of thought
acquaintances Francisco's famous
Chinatown in turn dipped its hand into
the audience for grab bag and let its
dragon rise and explode garland by the
flowers of California it's great and
it's proof were made more beautiful by
joyous girl who waved cordial greeting
to the crowd the ingenuity of men the
32000 am very tight having secured of
this apostle of arghya
[Music]
not satisfied with daytime semen but
working itself up into a frenzy that
even surpassed the daytime calibration
market speak gave its broad bosom to the
nighttime festivities that seemed a
classic expression of the earliest
inhabitants was definitely expressed by
the old gold miner who came down from
the hills downstairs there ain't never
been anything like this before and I
reckon won't never be again
[Music]
and meanwhile the sands of the shore
line was fastened opposite Fisherman's
Wharf by a garland of fireworks as
varied as California's flowers we have
said each to the other in honor to this
structure it is a job well done for
every state in the Union gave of their
industries to complete this bridge of a
billion ribbon the Garden of Babel and
the Sphinx of Egypt gives there to claim
to this new work of mankind the prayer
of the Pioneer mother has been answered
her sons have built the pen Francisco
Bay Bridge and we say to her mother
California we have sent you men to match
your Mountain
this is baled home movie footage of
Chinatown about 1927-28
a funeral in Chinatown a feature film
outtake don't know from what
another feature film outtake and then
the starless feature film outtake
see your existentialist moment of the
evening or maybe this top of the night
that's right yeah when we're doing sure
in this castle unpaved roads on
Telegraph Hill
working waterfront smokey filled with
the tracks of the Beltline railroad
after up close the building was for sale
for some time and now I think what it's
condos or something
so a recent discovery this is the good
life on Telegraph Hill in the middle of
World War two and in those days you
could sit on your porch or your veranda
3 or terrace and look at the working
navy fleet this is I'm one kind of uh
Nakata home of a from but just the you
know
[Music]
I'm surprised it actually Kodak process
this film because there be military
intelligence and you're not supposed to
photograph ships and ports and docks
during the war so look here this is more
time scrap metal drive on Telegraph Hill
maybe one of you can recognize this
right
tourists from about 1963 up at Coit
Tower
San Francisco is for people who enjoy
her sights and her scene San Francisco
is for people who like Motor Hotel
[Music]
San Francisco is for everybody
Sutras San Francisco is for you
[Music]
this is a home movie from who do you
think early 60s
and this is per sells a famous
african-american owned nightclub there's
the first building to be reconstructed
after the earthquake this is a something
I had to put in its shows an unfinished
pyramid wasn't always like this
all right let's let's have an ambient
moment outside the flood building
I love these feature film outtakes
because there's no requirement that
anything happens
this is to show the old was that the old
Redevelopment Agency down there that
beautiful deco USO the USO place here's
the highly contested mid-market
region today we'll just crossed Van Ness
heading east heading inbound more
surplice there's about 19 I feel like
it's about 48
not the Twitter building
[Applause]
all these great theaters good way to
spend the day or a week painless Parker
the dentist
that's in Harrison right by the Peraino
library
[Applause]
yeah just above the turntable I usually
you know I don't do the tourist cable
coil thing so much but these are just so
kind of gritty these shots
yeah Polk Street
so here we are at fenced in and Irving
now and Veronica's does anybody know the
history of this this Karl at the
boneyard from old rolling stock
my best guest says and I could be wrong
there's people around here tonight who
know much more about this than I do but
47 48 ish earlier that's the Irving
Theatre in the background
now of course offense is nothing to this
photographer
did somebody ask what happened to the
cars can anybody answer that
oh yeah a few own harbour shots and this
was kind of cool because in a minute
you're gonna see something that nobody
ever shopped I think because they
weren't supposed to this is about
again this is 47 48 ish from a totally
different source gulls not in danger
look there's the naval shipyard but you
never see fun a little bit of the
industrial southeast anybody know where
this is
so the Matteson line shoving off look
for Hawaii I would think I like that the
cheap cabins
I don't know offhand anybody want to
take a guess
mid to late 50s
all right I'll take hold on to your
fasten your seat belts
now take from the lineup that was now
we're coming up from the airport in the
early sixties and a stick you can buy a
seat if you want now
no mr. peanut I'm sorry
yeah that's why this is here 76 our
[Applause]
two-way traffic on the top trucks and
trains on the lower level
yeah that was not the bike path you
change direction you know I can't do a
whole evening of just this shot there's
so much of it
19:39 it's not beautiful it's like coal
or oil the fairies
the world's for Golden Gate
International Exposition in 1939 and
1940
does it matter it's the Berkeley so it's
presumably a it's an East Bay ferry I
could I can tell whether its key system
or Southern Pacific
[Applause]
China clipper and clipper Cove
so we had our World's Fair with with
foreign governments and American
government and state and city and county
exhibits and then we had also a little
bit of this more than a little bit of
this this is a family friendly show so
you're not seeing everything but this
was not a British environment every day
of the National Cash Register pavilion
would exhibit the number of visitors the
Gateway that's right
little buggers off to Asia an island
hopping trip
this was this was the gateway part of
the fair the amusement area Treasure
Island
these films were shot by the Ransa
Hoff's on the day when the workers at
Ransa Hoff's department store all went
to the fair
Sally ranch trans nude ranch
we're not going to go in inside tonight
I think this exhibit was a little more
educational than sexy with an erotic
[Music]
early footage of film or a street don't
know anything about it this has no
daughter of the Hirota family dr. Hirata
was a dentist in the Western Addition
hid these funds range from the 30s
there's a break during which they were
incarcerated during the war and then
they come out after the war again
these films are now on part of a
wonderful project the Center for Asian
American media is doing
memories to light-collecting home movies
and stories and background information
from Asian American families and doing
screenings and also making more work
with with film and video makers and they
do screenings around town there's no
tomorrow in San Jose in fact this is for
North Street
so dr. Hirata is back and he's got his
army jacket on and that is the insignia
of the 442 the most decorated army
regiment in history something like 7,000
purple hearts for 40,000 men made up
mostly of volunteers from men who were
incarcerated in the so called
internment camps during the war now
there are lots of people who shot high
angle shots through San Francisco out
their windows but most of them focused
on the north side of the city and the
bay and what's neat about these and I I
wish to quality or a little better but
they looked in every direction they
looked south so we're gonna see a little
bit of what yeah
Mission Control in further south looked
like in 1955
if you have a camera your job is to
document
giveme vironment like this
ceil Stadium
Sorry Sorry its history so for those of
you who don't know we're CEO Stadium
sorry right we'll leave in Candlestick
one of my favorites it's a flashback
from last year but just take a close
look and think about the the light level
of merchandising compared to today yeah
that's true too
we're leaving Candlestick Park oh gosh
63 could be 62
but I I mean I love this you'll see a
woman that you know she brought Ritz
crackers to the game to each he's not
eating $10 garlic fries
thanks to here we have the players all
lined up after the game they sure did a
swell job but they didn't quite make it
it's nevertheless in the background you
will see the members and their wives and
friends that were here today and to
encourage them in a victory we didn't
quite make it but better luck next time
boys they're all excited they're having
their pictures taken but in the short
time we all be together human oh boy
scissor trial a bit we're just about
ready to say goodbye for the day so
signing off for organ op Lodge boys next
time you have to get out and win again
so anybody know where this is I don't
mystery clip
so thanks to Scott Stark on the Sola
family on Prospect Street and Bernal
Heights movies that Scott's dark and
Kathleen Tyler discovered in their house
when they moved in this is war time I
think this is a victory garden there
were 80,000 Victory Gardens in San
Francisco during World War two we can
feed ourselves to a great extent control
freak
[Applause]
mom and I are doing all the work as
usual
so thanks to the Market Street Railway
this is a little film excerpt following
the route of the number 40 car which one
from San Francisco to San Mateo and I'm
going to violate my rule and we're going
to leave the city limits for just a few
seconds here Oh somebody would know more
than I would
Mission Street
the big intersection of Van Ness
Southland s mission etc with the great
arrows
going out mission Street
is this top of the hill daly city
coming if I'm not wrong coming around
the curve into the calmer
it's great to be alive in Kona that's
the town motto seriously
all right so thanks to the SF public
library this is Department of Public
Works documentation of 3rd Street a shot
every 50 feet six frames a second from
the city line up to South of Market so
look quickly
or seventies
next time I'd like to stop and visit in
the Bayview a little bit longer
you know Oklahoma Arts District
so this is our
[Music]
[Applause]
these are members of the Zellerbach
family and their friends riding around
in 1925
tricycle lane
a little slice of life in Pacific
Heights and the San Franciscans boast
that their city has a moderate
year-round temperature and the
healthiest climate in the world
the fog banks which roll in from the
Pacific are San Franciscans say nearly
invigorating sea mists bringing health
wealth and happiness for the wonder city
of the West
they creating sea mists so Scout parade
on the Irving Street I'm gonna I think
this is about 46 47 the Irving Theatre
14th to 15th Avenue if I'm not mistaken
sometime around 38 39 new construction
in the Sunset District and the days when
we're still out there out there so it's
this block or two of beautiful new
houses or these Brucella houses and man
fit the sand is just blowing all over
it's Easter Sunday but I love that kind
of build out another feature I'll take a
lot of empty lots you can see on where
the sand still rolls out here in the
sunset it was about 51 it's not fully
built out
I think there's 20 animals here and no
coyotes
did you read we have a hundred coyotes
in San Francisco now
this is one of my favorite pieces of
footage I think I showed it three or
four years ago it's people we would now
you know revile as as people that use
San Francisco is a place to party but
you know here we are it's 1929
prohibition is still going
we're in Golden Gate Park there's the
the waterfall at Huntington Falls don't
feed the birds but these people did
something which pops up again and again
and again in home movies before 1933
which is that they transgress they drink
very popular topic and home movies
you know this is like medical marijuana
little little tipsy
the camera is not even sled level
[Music]
so shipwrecks what is this this is the
Frank buck or is it the Frank buck and
this is the Ohio in 37-38 we've seen
this before this is some new footage I
haven't shown but what's really neat
about this is this is right off so those
are seal rocks they're what's really
neat about this is that it was a major
tourist attraction for a couple of years
till it broke up and and and this year
those footage to show exactly how much
with tourist attraction it was
you can still see bits and pieces along
the coastal trail at low tide there's
things that look like rocks but they
aren't rocks a little bit of the Golden
Gate Bridge
I don't think people took as many
pictures of our unfinished bay bridge as
they did of these two bridges in that
time
see if you dream about this image this
is the J family Cathy G who it's from
his courtesy we see these movies 'as in
the audience this is her brother
delivering the paper on 15th Avenue in
the Richmond District
we are still Lake
and an exciting moment on 15th in Balboa
but the the G brothers and some other
neighbors are jamming out on the
sidewalk when would you say this was
early 60s
about 62 says Kathy
I bet it's when the saints go marching
in
it's Kathy on the right the shorts let's
fill our streets with music
Playland there may be a few of you here
who don't know that we used to have a
great amusement park by the beach
suit rose after the
[Applause]
I would take from the movie the lineup
1957
and the skytram we have similar footage
this year of the skytran
went behind the baths now it's all a
wonderful woman
this is probably very late 60s very
early 70s just before all this was
demolished
so due to an unavoidable technical
glitch this is flopped but this is the
women's policy riding down the great
highway I think this is great
makes you want to shoot a surf western
or something
anybody want to talk about those
buildings we're passing
and those are the westernmost dwellings
in San Francisco and southeast Farallon
Islands part of Supervisors District 128
miles offshore a wildlife sanctuary in
the San Francisco lightship this is
about 1962 ish
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
we're building a dream for tomorrow
we're building
or tomorrow
we're trains that crops the hill the
land goes from the palm by night and day
and sunshine touches every hand in parks
where children play
and all along the way we're building the
dreams for tomorrow
we're building
for more
where
a dream for tomorrow
we're building the dream for tomorrow
[Applause]
let's hear it for the volunteers who've
made everything possible thank you
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you